let's take a look at uh the Anna
zatonski versus Jennifer U game as well
let's move to that one because I feel
that one is going to be over in just a
second unless happened here unless Anna
sacrificed a rook I don't like Black's
King oh my goodness Rook
A7 you want to play C5 and cover the
seventh rank you actually play the
spirit of left poki is alive this is how
you cover F7 he did this in the polyi
variation so if I go C5 I take on D4 I
capture with
Knight ah it's not made in one I had a
night to retreat but but it's not good
but it's just not a madeen one Rook
takes the now we understand this Rook
A7 but you're right there is G I can go
G4 if but I want something more again
I'm getting greedy maybe more than extra
night yeah more than that yes somehow